Chiari malformation is a brain
malformation leading to displacement of
the cerebellar tonsils
and in this Chiari malformation
there is a downward displacement of the
cerebellar tonsil through the foramen
magnum
now this is creating more pressure in
the brain stem and also blocks the
normal flow of the cerebrospinal fluid
there are two types of theory
malformation type 1 which lead to the
downward displacement of cerebral tonsil
only and type 2 which is more severe and
leading to the downward displacement of
cerebellar tonsil brain stem and the
food ventricle that is creating
hydrocephalus at its severe form
this is the diagnosis of the Chiari
malformation using MRI you can notice
that how the cerebellar tonsil has
protruded downwards in the upward MRI
2 malformation is most